say you're talking to someone at what
point does it become an offense like if
if if I'm talking to my friend and my
friend's like man my mom is being a
[__] [__] and I'm like why why don't
you just kill her as a joke and then he
kills her am
I in
trouble probably not
right but some people's style of joking
is really dry you know like what if I
was like oh well you should
definitely Hey look me you got to kill
her there's no way
out and then he does it and then he's
like dude me and Chris he gets caught
and he's like me and Chris Leah had this
plan to kill my mom and I'm just like I
that was a joke and the cops are like he
said you said it seriously I don't think
this should be something you can go to
jail for convincing people to kill
someone it man I don't know though it's
pretty crazy maybe if you have like a
[__] history of it you
know you should just go to jail for not
being a go-getter and not doing it
yourself
honestly but like that's a crazy thing
to go to jail for especially for a kid
right I don't know how old she was but
she's obviously not that old but
like yo yo you're just impressionable
huh guys are
dumb he probably thought he was in love
with her and [__] you know what I don't
get is this gypsy Rose Blanchard
story so she was released from
jail after eight years right
and she talked a guy into
killing her
mom oh yeah so Gypsy Ro Blanchard jypsy
Rose Blanchard the woman who persuaded
an online boyfriend to kill her mother
after he had forced her to pretend for
years after she had forced her to
pretend for years that she was suffering
from leukemia muscular dist is that what
that movie they made movies about it
yeah like those Hulu movies or whatever
the [__] persuaded an online boyfriend
to kill her mother after she had forced
her to pretend yeah so she got out on
parole was she a kid when she forced the
guy when she told the guy to do it it
turned out that she's fine she was
perfectly healthy 30 now 32 so she went
when she was she wasn't a kid what she
was 2 23 not yeah that's an adult uh not
development the latest her friends which
always believed uh you know this is
munchow and syndrome by proxy
obviously um that's a weird one
huh um it's you just want attention huh
people were the for how good of a mom
you are for helping how weird dude oh
yeah uh they received donations and [__]
wow so that's fraud that's fraud so
that's an offense but dude convincing
someone that person is kind of just a
[__]
honestly that's really wild uh all right
well that's she's out of prison which
is damn what if she couldn't help
herself if she just convinced someone
else to kill someone again